[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER 1: Firstly, we
accept no responsibility for
any damage caused by
playing the game.
MALE SPEAKER 2: We were hoping
that the game was going to
work as kind of a social
lubricant in Hangouts.
The goal was just to make
something really
ridiculous and fun.
One of the key things about
having a game with a lot of
little micro games in it, was
it was good for getting
everyone on the team a little
piece of the project
that they could own.
MALE SPEAKER 1: The creative
process went from the very
start to the very end of
the production cycle.
MALE SPEAKER 2: All the key
points that we wanted to
fulfill with the ideas, ranging
from feasibility right
up to awesomeness, so we
had to tick all the
boxes in each concept.
MALE SPEAKER 1: I think we did
some prototyping and some
testing just to see what sort of
data came out of it and how
we might use it.
We had a basic system just to
begin with and it kind of
quickly became apparent that
it wasn't going to hold up.
We went back to the drawing
board, basically, and spent a
lot more time planning out
how all the multi-player
interaction was going to work.
We were trying to hit a game
a day for the [INAUDIBLE]
in the second week, and
we almost got there.
I think we were planning
on doing five games.
We ended up getting to four.
We had a lot of squeaking
seats.
You'd be sitting around coding
and you'd just hear the
[SQUEAKING NOISE].
You'd turn around and someone
would be like rocking around
on their seats.
[MUSIC PLAYING]